miss excused abortion
the along Blair comes are they
je crois eh merci beaucoup Poland's at
ser professor say it's a it's a dream
come true to be here never thought this
would happen okay this is an ambitious
title I'm only going to touch on a few
things but I think all of us know French
in action is of course the greatest
language course ever created but it's
much more than that for so many of us
and that's who I am and I am at Cornell
University so I'm gonna get right to the
heart of the matter at the beginning
here is French in action occults this
this this subject came up yesterday
briefly so let's let's have a look at
the evidence
so some characteristics of cults cults
arise spontaneously around novel beliefs
and practices that are claimed to offer
an exclusive path to enlightenment
so as you see here in this article in
The Economist immersion method makes all
other language courses obsolete
exclusive path also also cults
frequently often are tapes and videos to
watch another characteristic of thought
cultists engaged in prolong worship
sessions to achieve a trancelike state
often neglecting nutrition sleep work
and family I'll call your attention to
this this phenomenon of the the viewers
and educators say we the public TVs
French and action marathons
other characteristics of cults excessive
devotion to a charismatic leader
and so I like this notice notice the
raised finger and here he was yesterday
and here's some of the excessive devote
well I would I wouldn't say excessive
but devotion certainly cult disassembled
from across the world the short notice
when called by their leader and just
just have a look at this and is it is it
just me or does this room look look like
a church a little bit a veneration of
individual priests and priestesses who
are regarded as higher beings by their
flock
and I I couldn't help but notice I
couldn't help but notice that there was
a non random distribution of males and
females around our to our two high
priests yesterday here's here's Charles
and here's a Valerie use of cryptid or
coded language that immediately
identifies one member of the cult to
another but gives little away to the
outsider and so anyway here here are
these are all easier all phrases that I
use a lot and anybody who's also in the
cult would it would to be able to tell
it yes you must have learned your French
from French and action to take Bianchi
fini beyond any any view that I have is
a view on table bizarre bizarre when I
see a nun I immediately think and roll
the bun sir whether she's droll or not
mister he bulled a gum of course we
could probably all probably run through
2020 more but but when I hear an
American speaking French and they use
one of these phrases AHA you you're one
of us devotees of cults undertake
pilgrimages to sites regarded as sacred
so I mean sassy
Namrata Hotel Rome rotten and who in
Paris who among us hasn't made sure to
visit this place and we have our
pictures taken in front of it and of
course the font and amid sea and of
course you have to you have to visit the
closer read Delilah and have a kir
Royale and of course you have to go Oh
sue soul to see the telephone booth
where robear tried to make his phone
call and if you if you've done so you
know that there's no what if still there
but there's no telephone any longer and
you have to visit a course all of the
all the cafes featured in French in
action and at least have a coffee there
and as you say yes the root of OG of our
and a a mystery bootleg um where is this
we Truffaut shavar it's the back of the
Odeon theatre and so you can go there
say yes you can you confirm for yourself
that I there's something something is
strange here and then of course you go
to walk around the block - Towanda
Rubina me and here's the hallow'd here's
some of the the tear sock faith for us
French in action fans and if you like me
you'll take a lot of hundred photographs
of this of this building and and there's
Towanda and a beautiful beautiful
building of course and look at that
there's the the balcony where where
robear and me they had their had their
conversation and it looks just like it
does in the videos there's the doorbell
and LuPone de la concorde there is a
nice scene there of course and and you
have to have you in front of the font
the Stravinsky fountain there with the
with the with the lips I mean I could
imagine that that could be there should
be a French and action themed tour of
Paris I think there enough of us that
that that a tourist agency in Paris
could offer this on the web and make a
killing basically if you have if you
have only a couple days in Paris they
could guarantee that they'll you know
you'll hit all the all the important
spots but one positive so Colts often
have that but the term alpha has a
pejorative connotation but one thing I
think is good about our cults is that
questions are tolerated here there are a
lot of good questions yesterday and so I
am the I am the creator of the Mustapha
Buddha gum French in action blog and I
just give you a little background on how
it got started it's it actually started
with on a blog of a woman named Lily
Anna Segura a New York City writer and
this blog no longer exists was called
fancy robot and in 2003 she wrote one
blog article on French and action and
and then the the comment thread that
followed her article became the de facto
unofficial french in action discussion
site and and so the the comment thread
there were comments added for the
following four years and people asking
when aware are where are the actors
today wouldn't a reunion be a fantastic
thing to do to have all kinds of things
and even Charles Mayer
to the blog and shared some of his
recollections which was wonderful and
kind of kind of kept it going and then
one day the blog disappeared and with it
all that that whole common thread came
to an end and and this was at the time
when my wife and I were planning a
honeymoon in Paris and I was gia had
another another reason to watch all 52
French and action episodes again to
brush up on my French now it's thinking
wow there needs to be a blog on French
Connection an unofficial blog where
people can can share their and why they
love French in action ask questions and
it would be cool of course if we could
get some some of the the people involved
in French and action to share their
recollections with us and so this idea
that French in action is a cult derived
from from from this this fancy robot
French and action thread and so here's a
comment left by somebody in 2007 the
funny thing is that Wikipedia lists this
thread as a cult page for French and
action Valerie Allen we French and
action fans are indeed when petits
associate a and then somebody responds
this is a cult so calling it a cult page
is accurate well whenever people get
together and do what we do over our
topic that would make the mainstream
citizen of the world go hmm you got a
cult
and anyway so here's there's their
number of wonderful comments on this on
this thread and so one thing on the
French and actually on the mystery Blue
Gum blog using the what's it called the
internet wayback machine basically saves
in a cache everything that ever appeared
on the Internet we've I've reposted that
whole thing on the blog and a number of
you know there's always a few off-color
comments of course but but there's some
that are wonderful this is one I this
one's kind of typical and you know one
of the reasons why I really thought this
is well a wonderful thing this person
says here's how I imagine French and
action to could begin in episode 53 we
meet we meet professor Capretta and his
new cohort a cohort of students in
episode 54 we learned that ro-bear
stayed in France and is now happily
married with Miffy one of their children
is about 19 years old and will be the
one of be one of the two central
characters of French and action to as
many as possible the original cast will
reprise their original roles though
they'll be smaller roles because the
minerals be played by actors and
actresses who were in diapers when the
original series was released just
imagine charles maya returns as papa
robear and valerie islands mama mia mama
mia vay
Virginie contest is taunted marvel or
who we learn grew up and stole the heart
of an heir to the renault fortune tones
mikhailovna trivita helado
des voix de bello Wazir le to german
vikon's a b.src a crab de foie de la
ilaha chance or maybe instead of
marriage Marie Laure achieved great
success in some field of endeavor
because of her own pluck and spirit but
just writing the paragraph above imagine
that robear and the below family have a
future gave me goosebumps I don't know
why I care so much about these people
who aren't even real I think these
feelings might be caused or enhance them
how by immersion in a foreign language
maybe this kind of immersion makes it
easier for a brain to form emotional
bonds like a babies or toddlers brain
possibly this could even explain some of
the excess emotions at surface and some
of the comments above
posted by an Otsuka robear okay
here's somebody else you wrote and I'm
writing a second 52 chapters for French
and action it's going to be it's going
very slowly because my French is not
that good and it's difficult to think of
plot lines as engaging as those in the
original French in action
everybody's 20 years older of course
Mira is married to robear and has three
kids collect is married to bear whose
family went broke he's now a barber and
Massey lore is engaged to be married to
an older man jean-michel who is no
longer a communist but has become a very
successful and wealthy industrialist
lomond war is skulking around again but
we don't know why bizarre bizarre so I
just kind of curious how many people
have seen the mystery Bulldog on blog oh
wow I'm impressed
well I'm I'm a little embarrassed about
the blog because as you know if you've
seen it I write an article for it about
once every four months or so it's and my
my my intention was sort of to provide a
forum for this ongoing kind of
discussion and actually I think maybe
that's how it's more successful is on
the discussion page of the blog and for
those of you who haven't been there I
invite you to to to have a look and I
also invite you to do a contribute